[Música]
revista 'la prensa' directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez masdéu conmigo ya
en el estudio rosa bienvenida buena
mañana del miércoles vamos a dedicar
toda esta sección de revista de prensa
del día de hoy a desgranar la entrevista
que le hizo la bbc de rosa como estamos
adelantando a mariana vicente y que dice
mi foto fue utilizada para difundir
mentiras sobre la guerra porque dice eso
y recordemos entonces de qué se trata
esta foto buenos días raúl exactamente
si te parece veamos la imagen a la que
nos referimos
protagonizada como decías por mariana
visiones y esta joven ucraniana una
imagen que seguro tú recordarás sería
mucha de nuestra audiencia porque fue
una de las imágenes icónicas de la
guerra en ucrania esta imagen recordemos
fue tomada por mi isla chernoff un
fotógrafo de la agencia estadounidense
ap a sus 73 el 9 de marzo tras un ataque
aéreo ruso sobre uno de los hospitales
maternales de mariupol y de hecho esta
imagen pues ha circuló por internet fue
portada de muchos medios internación
incluso fue comentada en el consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas sin embargo
la protagonista dice mills que tal y
como cuenta a la periodista del medio
británico la bbc- también que se llama
mariana mariana spring en este caso tras
a la circulación internacional de estas
imágenes ella fue blanco de una campaña
de acoso y tal y como pues describe muy
bien la periodista de la bbc- después de
haber sobrevivido a un ataque marianas
enfrentó otro ataque desinformación y
odio contra ella y su familia y es que
es necesario recordar que después del
bombardeo de este hospital maternal de
mariupol rusia no es que negará la
autoridad del ataque como ha hecho en
otras ocasiones sino que lo justificó
diciendo que se era un centro de
operaciones del batallón as 2 y también
insistió en que ésta y otras imágenes
fueron una escenificación además rosa
como usted lo dijo una significación
ella fue acusada de actuar y no
solamente interpretar digamos a ese
papel según lo dice rusia sino a dos
mujeres dos papeles diferentes en esta
actuación según rusia
no esta campaña de desinformación
promovida tanto por medios estatales
rusos sino también por altos
funcionarios de moscú se basó en dos
elementos y es que tal y como vamos a
ver aquí detrás en este trino
exactamente de la embajada rusa en reino
unido antes de la guerra pues mariana
promocionaba productos de belleza en
instagram y su esposo raúl a yuri de
hecho trabajaba en la acería de us
hostal no que tanto estamos comentando
últimamente bien pues rusia acusó a
mariana visión y script de haber usado
sus conocimientos de maquillaje para
fingir no las heridas que se ve una tan
claramente en la foto y por otro lado es
que cabe recordar que mariana no fue
solamente la protagonista de esta imagen
que veíamos en portada sino que también
aparece en otra instantánea de ese
momento post ataque del hospital no y es
que vemos esta foto que comentábamos con
el edredón pero también en la otra
imagen que ahora veremos a continuación
tomada por el beni malo le trata también
de asociar siempre se la ve bajando por
las escaleras del hospital así es rossi
para entender entonces estas dos
imágenes es preciso conocer el relato
del momento estas dos imágenes que vemos
ahí atrás de usted rosa exactamente ella
explica que el nuevo el 9 de marzo
cuando tuve cuando tuvo lugar este
ataque estaba charlando con las otras
mujeres en una de las salas del hospital
maternal imagina raúl estar esperando
para dar a luz en el momento en que tu
ciudad' mariupol es la masa bombardeada
en una guerra no en este caso en la
guerra de ucrania bueno estaba charlando
cuando de repente oyeron una primera
explosión luego una segunda explosión
ella dice podías escuchar todo volando
metralla y esas cosas entonces las
mujeres embarazadas fueron desplazadas
para refugiarse en el sótano del
hospital con otros civiles pero ella
dijo necesitaba recuperar todas mis
pertenencias todo lo que había preparado
para mi bebé para veronica la hija que
estaba esperando entonces pidió a un
policía que la acompañara a las
instalaciones del hospital maternal
donde se encontraba anteriormente para
recuperar todas sus pertenencias
fue aquí cuando fue tomada la otra
instantánea de apeht e inmediatamente
cuando fueron publicadas estas imágenes
se viralizó aaron porque como decíamos
cabe recordar que el equipo de ap en ese
momento era el único equipo de
periodistas internacionales que se
encontraba en mariupol una ciudad pues
que ya tenía ya estaba bastante
incomunicado a principios de marzo y que
estas imágenes fueron una ventana a lo
que estaba pasando en esta sitiada
ciudad portuaria hablas rosa de la
viralización de estas dos de imágenes
pero había preguntó entonces leyendo
esta entrevista de la bbc que las que
estamos desgranando en toda esta revista
de prensa cuando ella realmente se da
cuenta que su rostro ha estado
circulando por todo el mundo además que
ha sido víctima de una campaña de
desinformación a - pues claro en los
primeros días ella primero da a luz en
otro hospital de mariupol y luego
intenta huir de la ciudad durante varias
semanas y en esos momentos sin acceso a
internet no es consciente de que está
protagonizando esta enorme campaña de
desinformación por parte de las
autoridades rusas ni que está haciendo
pues también protagonista de estas
icónicas imágenes del sufrimiento de los
civiles en esta guerra
cuando entré a instagram unos días
después de que está inundado de mensajes
acusatorios y amenazantes dice recibí
amenazas de que vendrían a buscarme que
me matarían que cortarían a mi hijo en
pedazos pero no solamente critica a
rusia de esta campaña sino también a pep
para que por qué no pues consiguieron
más testimonios para contrastar dice que
ese ataque tuvo lugar y bueno finalmente
tal y como cuenta mariana springs la
periodista de la bbc- puede ser ya la
protagonista de estas imágenes se
encuentra en el donbass y parece que
está a salvo tal y como le explicó ella
misma en la entrevista y confirmaron sus
familiares y amigos rosa gracias como
siempre por esta revista de prensa un
tema tan interesante y pues que esta
mujer y su bebé finalmente están a salvo
que es lo más importante en este sentido
en esta guerra rosa gracias pasamos a
saludar a nuestra primer invitado